hey there folks Chris waters here
welcoming you to a special sponsored
segment of our e3 show coverage joining
me on the couch
I have Roy Lew from line Cong
interactive and Charles young the VP of
fuse games and fuse is the name of this
segment here because we are here to talk
about a new console Charles tell us the
name of this console it's pretty
exciting
yeah as you may know that is a Chinese
console market has been banned for 14
years yeah so probably most people know
about the PlayStation the Xbox but I'd
say most people around here know about
yeah but that's you cannot imagine that
most of the Chinese people doesn't know
about too much about console games so I
think fuse is not only a new brand for
them but also a new product for them in
the last year that Microsoft and Sony
has entered the chinese market
officially but they didn't do much well
for them but so that's I think that's a
good chance for us to do a new product a
new console for the Chinese audience
because as you may know that back to the
end of 90s the start of the end of 80s
at the start of the 90s that we Chinese
market has like some kind of copycat of
a Nintendo Entertainment System aha
hello was sold over 20 million units
shipped in Chinese market yeah there's a
copycat but since then since then that
we don't have some kind of what we call
official council has entered the Chinese
market so we think this is a big
potential here and now the government
has released the restrict we can do that
for the video game market so that's why
we bring the views f1 to the Chinese
audience I think a whole opportunity
yes that's much cheaper that much more
may football for the Chinese audience
Chinese players and it's not that there
aren't gamers in China there are
millions and millions of them but
they're predominately playing games on
mobile devices is that right yeah that's
right that's right that's because for
the previous years the mobile game is an
online game it was so popular to the
Chinese audience but I think that's not
because they don't play the console baby
the console games the big problem is
they don't know what console game is
because the console gamer was bad
in there yeah can I get any news from
the record a news channel so that's why
they don't know anything about the
council gaming so that's why we want to
bring a real because we know that we
have players we know that real games was
on a council level so that that is why
we want to do some kind of council
version or Council to the Chinese
audience all right so you mentioned Xbox
one PlayStation 4 ah you know the Wii U
that's sort of our current generation of
consoles yeah talk to us about how the
fuze f1 fits you know comparing with
those in terms of technical
specifications uh what I want to say
that we are not competitors for them
that for the Chinese because currently
you want to focus on the Chinese market
these are the priorities are majority
yeah I think we are not competitors on
those markets we are partners for market
what do we want to try to do as I said
we have a big potential here what do we
want to do is a wake wake it up we want
to activate this sleeping console market
yeah so maybe I think that PlayStation 4
and Xbox one was alike as some kind of
high-end machine higher and further for
this for this market and what fuels will
f1 wanted to this we are aiming the
middle turn of the market we want to
bring some kind of product was as low as
the low-end machine just like angel box
or something like that
haha follow we provide the game the
console advocate was as close as it can
be to the high-end games so I think
that's a good chance for the Chinese
audience to use a very low price to buy
some kind of council box that play the
game that maybe they were getting
interested in them then maybe they could
become someone high level players sure
so I think they could have their choice
whatever they play for the few seven or
listening for Xbox one they are all
players we are all players absolutely
and I think that's it that's a great
niche to try to fill I mean we don't
really have a console like that you know
you gotta go 300 400 dollars get into
console gaming these days unless you
know you're going back a few generations
the Xbox 360 or something like that yeah
that song is alright that's right
okay so why one one technical question
actually they came to mind does it is it
taking discs or is it connecting to the
Internet to download games sort of
what's the format ah we don't have any
discs we don't have any physical
material for a package let's all
download the ball form from the internet
great yeah and you got the controller
design here it looks familiar look at
like the Xbox one controller you know
certainly a great controller that we're
all enjoying here yeah because that's a
big question for us because you know as
I said that the whole market was banned
for 14 years yeah that's not a short
full audience but also sure for someone
who has the experience to work in the
console a video game market so we really
really want to build something new
something totally different something
unique or for the Chinese audience but I
think the first thing we want to do is
try to make it is easier for the
developers to bring their games to our
platform yeah so we don't want to create
something totally different we just want
to make them feel familiar for this
platform so we want three because we
know that why you play console it's not
you playing the hardware you are playing
the games you are playing the software
we are the most of other more games do
we have the more chance you can attract
the Chinese audience so that's why we
want to try something more easier for
developers they can't bring as much as
much as much as they can the games they
want to put on our platform well with
the Chinese console market reopened and
so many options come in the market I
wish you gentlemen the best of luck
certainly seems like an exciting project
and I hope it goes well because hey more
gamers is better for everybody right yep
Thank You Charles
Roy for coming on to talk about the fuse
f1 here at e3 2016